on today's show we're gonna be talking
about adult themes so watch out for the
little ears in the room we're gonna be
talking about social media
technology and my 10-month adventure
using the social media platforms we're
also going to be talking to a new dad
trying to figure out how to set
boundaries for him and his family and
his little one
we're going to talk to a mom of a 17
year old girl who's trying to make sure
she stays connected
before her daughter leaves home stay
tuned
hey yo this is john and this is the dr
john dolone show
it's a live show where we take your
calls
about your hearts your messes your good
stuff your bad stuff
your happiness your sadness all of it
we're all learning how to be human
beings again
some of you don't like your neighbor
some of you don't like people on the
other side of the country some of you
don't like people on the other side of
the social medias
and we're cutting through all that
nonsense and we're getting down to the
things that connect us
as human beings as people all on the
same team
all who are probably pretty smart all of
us have
experiences and loves and hurts and
we're all
figuring out how to come together we
talk about everything on the show
family issues mental health issues
relational iq
love loss and we also
highlight what's going right things that
are
good things that are good i received
this email
ah it's so good from judith lee and
here's what judith writes
i'm an emergency room nurse who has
worked all through the pandemic in a
crazy environment
she also teaches future nurtures nurses
as an adjunct faculty member
she's 54 years old and she says i stay
exhausted most of the time
but the email's not about me she writes
my husband tommy and i have been married
for 28 years
some good some not good but i want to
give a shout out to my awesome husband
starting in march of this year she
started working the 7
p.m to 3 a.m shift 54 years old
the overnight shift and her husband goes
to bed and wakes up at 3 30 a.m
to meet me downstairs with my robe and
slippers
and he puts my scrubs in the washer he
does most of the cooking
the grocery shopping the laundry he's
become a better cook than me
he's also a loving son helping his mom
and my mom whenever they need something
and he's also been sharing his passion
of lacrosse and football coaching
in the community with for the last 15
years but isn't just just
about tasks he performs it's what this
means to me
and he supports me and he loves my
family
he's always there for our two boys both
living at home
during this pandemic mess and this time
has proven that he is supportive
protective and loving
the world is a better place because of
his contributions
tommy my brother we salute you judith
an absolute gangster working the night
shift in the middle of a pandemic as an
emergency room nurse
we salute you and most importantly i
want to thank you both
for showing us that the nightly news
isn't all the news
there is in fact there are stories over
and over and over again
about husbands setting their alarms
rolling over when it comes on at 3 30 in
the morning
knowing that his exhausted wife is gonna
come stumbling into the door
not that he's got a job to do not that
he's got some tasks to perform
but he's got somebody he can love and
love deeply
by being there to catch her when she
falls through the front door
he can be there to help provide food
he's still working his full-time job
right it's not like he's not tired but
he's there
guys who lean into connection ladies who
lean into connection
i salute you thank you so much we talk
about all of it on this show all right
so give me a call
1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693-3291
shoot me an email at ask john
ramseysolutions.com
that's ask john ramseysolutions.com
and let's go straight to the phones
let's go to eric in phoenix arizona
eric you've been waiting a long time
good man thank you so much for hanging
out what's going on
hey john so my wife and i just had a
baby a couple months ago
congratulations my brother thanks my
brother wants to come visit us for
thanksgiving but
he's had a history of some drug issues
and so we're having trouble
deciding whether we enforce a boundary
um
or maybe don't enforce the boundary and
try to save the relationship
okay tell me about the drug issues
first so it's mostly marijuana that we
know of but like a lot of this is
secondhand right so we don't know
everything he's doing we just know
that it's been going on for five or six
years and um
and it's just hard to it's hard to talk
about it he never wants to talk about it
when we
uh when i try to bring it up it always
kind of gets heated
um what is it when you say it gets
heated it kind of gets heated what does
that mean
well we have different opinions about
like you know you could say politically
about whether marijuana is good or not
sure um but we like i've seen how it
just
it doesn't help him how much it does and
maybe he just uses too much of it you
know
and so you know if we ever so we just
avoid that subject but he knows that
we've got this boundary that hey you
need to
pass a clean drug test if you want to
come see your nephew
and we're at the point where we're not
sure if he's going to pass it and so
are you guys giving him the drug test
um is he
yeah so he my parents have been giving
him drug tests and so they were going to
give it to him before he
came out like with them because he's
still living at home right now
why are they giving him drug tests
well they've set boundaries for him too
saying if you don't pass a drug test
you know you're kicked out of the house
you know and they've done that a couple
times but they always let them back in
okay and so that's the other hard thing
is we we want to set a sperm boundary
because we feel like he's never
had that you know so
it sounds like there's two issues here
one is you are feeling
like you need to lean in and become the
parent that your parents are not being
for your brother
that's number one number two is you are
trying to determine whether it's a
safety issue
with your new child is that fair
right and honestly well yeah and
honestly it's not a safety issue
so much with uh him like i don't believe
he's gonna be
dangerous or violent or anything we just
um but we want to we want to stick true
to our word because we want that to mean
something too you know
yeah i want to say we're going to do
something and then don't do it i get
that and so
when you say you gave this word right
you put something
you you drew a line here's my values
which you're allowed to have your values
right
did you tell him that did you all have a
conversation about it how did he get
that information
we told him probably over a year ago
before we were even pregnant because we
had some
miscarriages in the past and so we had
told him hey this is going to be
a thing for the future that you're going
to think about and we reminded him again
during the pregnancy
and and that was just over text message
but he was like yep okay and and it's
been weird because he's been talking
more
he doesn't talk to me directly about it
he always i hear stuff secondhand
to my parents yeah so how old are you
how are you i'm 25. okay how old is he
22. okay so it's time for
you to be a grown-up and i'm not saying
that i'm not making fun of you i'm just
saying
there's you're about to level up now
okay uh you're a dad
you're a husband you're in it now okay
and there's these moments
when young men level up young women do
it too but i'm just talking to you right
now
so you're going to level up and that
means you are absolutely 100
through having any sort of meaningful
conversation
whatsoever to anybody in your life on
text message
cool uh text message can be about
um what time are y'all showing up
tonight hey my flight got delayed i'll
be there at six that stuff's cool
but when you're gonna lay down value
statements like
you cannot see this baby if you are not
passing a
a drug test that's a in person
conversation
and if he doesn't want to have it you
can tell him i've got some stuff that i
need to talk to you about my new baby
and my small family
when you're ready to be grown up and
have a conversation give me a call okay
and he's gonna have to level up to but
number one this is not a
a conversation for um text message
number two
i want you and your wife to sit down and
make some clear
like what is the purpose of this value
this value judgment
like i said do you think that somebody
smoking weed
or who smoked weed a few days ago who's
gonna come and then
see their new nephew or their niece is
going to harm the child
or hurt the child if that's what you
think and believe and you've got some
wisdom
i've never seen that but i also know
that everybody's different okay
if that's what your kid if you worry
about the safety of your baby that's a
no quarter thing
nobody gets a vote on the safety of your
kid you draw hard boundaries to where
you think they should be and you hold
firm to them
if a year ago you had
like you were leaning into trying to
support your parents and saying yeah
and not only you're not going to get to
live with mom and dad but you're not
going to be able to see your new niece
and you sent that via text message i'm
going to tell you've got full permission
to circle back to your brother have a
grown-up brother to brother conversation
about man how are you doing and
we're getting ready to be in the
holidays mom and dad have asked you to
quit smoking
and they have said this is part of their
rules that you're gonna for you to live
in their house you keep failing them
what's what's going on bro because you
cannot bring drugs into my house
you can't because whatever state we live
in they're illegal i don't want them
here it's my house i get to make that
rule
what i don't want you to do man eric is
i don't want you to use your kid
as uh for ransom for your brother
i don't want you to use a powerful
relationship between
nephew or niece and an uncle
as as a way as a behavior manipulation
tool
because that's never going to work it's
not going to help him get sober
and that's not going to help you
feel better and so it sounds like
there's something deeper here if i'm if
i'm
leaning into it it sounds like you are
frustrated with your parents
you're frustrated with your brother and
you are trying to take this on is that
fair or am i out to lunch on that
yeah i mean there's a piece of it um
that's very true there i think the other
the other part of the boundary that we
set was also for
my wife's brothers there's a couple
one in particular that has probably some
more serious drug issues that would be
more
of a safety concern yeah and so i think
i think that we're trying to
set a boundary we're saying hey we're
enforcing this fairly on both sides
uh really relationships aren't fair
relationships aren't fair
um and don't feel that pressure
right if one is has a conviction
for selling cocaine and the other is
just out of being a teenager and got in
trouble for smoking marijuana those are
two different planets
as far as i'm concerned yeah and it does
make it easier on you guys just to do a
blanket
you know big square fence around the
house and again those are if these are
your values dude
go for it there is not going to be an
easy way to enforce these
boundaries and what i mean by easy
there's not going to be a way that
people don't walk away from your fence
that you build
with their hearts broken that's life
and if if addiction was as easily
it was cured as easy as just saying well
then you can't do this until you're done
we would have no addiction problems
but addiction is often a connection
issue it's a
relationship issue and so instead of
putting up roadblocks now it doesn't
have to be your kid hear me say that
but if you really want to help your
brother
deep in your relationship with him
connect with him reach
out to him talk to him once a week twice
a week via phone go visit him you all
set up camping trips together
and you lean into that relationship then
you will earn the currency to say hey
what's really going on
and he might say you had the same mom
and dad as me you know exactly what's
going on
or you know about this or you know some
stuff that i never told you
and it may be that he chooses smoking
weed
and you choose to work 90 hours a week
you're both running
yours is just socially acceptable and
his isn't right
or it may be that he's just he's a
a punk 22 year old who just wants to get
high doesn't care what other people say
and he needs to be slapped upside the
head and not living at mom and dad's
house and not
mooching free meals off holidays right
only you know that
but i don't think you have to draw a
comparison between a safety issue and a
22 year old who
may smoke weed a week before he comes to
see you those seem like
radically different things to me and you
just have to make peace with the fact
that you have a kid now
and every boundary you draw from here
now it's going to be hard
somebody's going to hit up against that
boundary with their face and their
forehead and their feet and their fists
and their knees and their
and their and their entire body's trying
to knock those boundaries over
and you're gonna have to hold firm to
them you and your wife are
and so what i would circle back here's
how i would approach this moving forward
i would circle back eric and i would
have a conversation with your wife
conversation number one is what are we
trying to do what are we trying to
accomplish
is all of this stuff because we don't
want that one brother she has
who's a violent offender or who makes
dangerous decisions with drugs coming to
our house for the holidays because if
it's so
call it what it is don't punish other
family members for one person's
idiocracy
or one person's illness or one person's
struggle
don't do that so get with your wife and
say what are we really trying to
accomplish are we trying to have a drug
free house if so
sweet send that notice to everybody call
them in person
hey you cannot come here unless you pass
a drug test to walk in my house
okay i don't i don't know anybody doing
that but you are
free to do that okay um if you want to
help
co-parent your brother he's 22 he's a
grown man stop doing that
be his brother love him lean into him
lean into him my brother and i who i
love more than life itself
we've had some great conversations over
the year i gave him some behavioral
mandates at one point
that wasn't super helpful but i was
young and thought i was
you know like i'll i'll be there right i
said you can do these things
you can't do these things or i'm going
to show up and then you have to deal
with me or whatever
and i don't know if that was helpful
probably not threatening someone you
love is usually not the best way but
um i also loved him and i was trying to
love him the best way i could
so if you back out eric um
what are you really trying to accomplish
here
yeah i i mean i want to circle up with
my wife like you said but i
i do think that it's more of um more of
that safety for the other brother and i
definitely
want to i don't want to be don't want to
set that don't want to hold this
boundary
i would rather have him come i'd rather
have him meet his um his nephew because
that's the other thing is he is
he is by far like the most excited but
he cried when he found out we were
pregnant no one else
like my parents didn't even cry like
he's excited and so i want to i really
want to
nurture that relationship and does your
wife like it build a relationship
oh yeah well he can be annoying but
that's a brother or ah
man you should see you talk to my
brother and sister i'm the most annoying
guy there is man so yeah
um when it comes dude yeah when it comes
to him um
you haven't told me anything that would
say no you can't be here
you can full full fledge that you will
not come into my house hi
i have told that to people that i love
right
you can't yeah and that's a different
thing hi you can't come to my house for
drugs you got to be safe when you come
to my house
but you're welcome here um i dude i love
that you want to deepen that
relationship with him
i mean that's noble that's noble let
your parents be parents and you be the
brother
and now that you're both in your 20s
you're both grown-ups now you're both on
your way to becoming wise grown men
seek some other men in your life that
can speak into this relationship
you be the guy that goes first lean into
your brother
love him the best that you know how and
then when you don't say
what are you missing man how can i be a
better brother have that conversation
for how's that for vulnerability right
and yeah talk to your wife about what
your values are and how you're going to
rally around your kid
and never be too big this is a this is
something i want to say to everybody
never be too big to say i drew a really
hard
boundary a year ago and a year later
that was dumb
i i mean i overshot that one right
like i you know we all know that person
that when they
have their first kid you go into their
house and they're spraying you down with
lysol and making you wash your hands
this is pre-covered of course
and take your shoes off and leave them
out in the yard we all know those people
and then a year later like dude yeah
whatever and they're picking the
the pacifier out of the dog food bowl
and just shoving it back in the kid's
mouth
don't be too big to say i drew a line it
was wrong
that's the world we're in right now with
politics and media
right i said it four years ago and if i
go back and change my mind because i've
got new data
i got new science i got new uh
relationship
relational information i can't change my
mind because everybody's nuts
the sign of a evolving
wise mind is that they hold their values
tightly
and their beliefs loosely and they are
not afraid to say i'm sorry
they're not afraid to say man i screwed
that up i want to go again
so good for you eric lean into that
brother but start with your wife start
with the values conversation
and i feel like this call was kind of
rambly i was kind of rambling on you
um because it's got it feels like it's
all over the place
but i hope if you're listening to this
you hear yourself in one of these
conversations
does everything have to be equal across
all my brothers and sisters
is there such thing as a easy hard
conversation with family
no is drawing value based boundaries
hard
yes is it uncomfortable yes can those
change
yes is
doing hard drugs and safety issues
different than a 22 year
old who's just still smoking weed and
he's just trying to get his life
together yes
yes and yes is there something different
between loving my brother
trying to be his super other parent yes
all of it
all of it but lean into default two
relationships
and default to keep your kids safe
appreciate your brother eric all right
let's go to
you know what before we go to the next
call
i gotta just this is me being vulnerable
here
so i started at this job uh about
10 months ago now totally new um i had
been living a life to where i didn't
want to
exist on the internet i was trying super
hard to not
i never i didn't even know there was
something as a youtube channel i didn't
know what that was
um i didn't i listened to like the same
two or three or four podcasts i was just
off
media i just wanted to be intentional
about being in the lives of the people
around me
and so about nine or ten months ago i
took this job here
and i got social media i got
instagram i told the team i would not
ever
um i don't know how to do some of these
other platforms and so they would take
my posts off of instagram and post some
other places
and sometimes i'll lean into some of
this stuff but i'm gonna
do one instagram post today and
i tell you what you take
my introduction as an old person as a 40
year old into
social media and then you dump on that a
contentious election
and a lot of coveted stuff and
the health literature i'm a nerd still i
stay in the in the literature a lot
so i'm keeping up with some of these
scientists who are cranking stuff out
trying to figure out what's happening
with the election all the things
and suddenly i find myself violating one
of my core
tenants one of my deepest cores personal
values
which is people before screens
long form books over tiny
tidbits of information a
a podcast over
a twitter feed
right reading science papers actually
going to pubmed actually going to
nature going to some of these journals
and reading the articles for myself
versus just going to some influencers
interpretation of the science
and here's me being vulnerable 10 months
later dude i have completely
crashed i spend way too much time on
instagram
dude that thing is like heroin it's been
way too much time it's it's a pain in
the butt to go get the actual study
i have a service that i have the
articles from all over the world
shipped to my inbox every week on
different topics right
on eating disorders and on anxiety and
on covet i have they ship
straight to my inbox i don't have to go
find them
and man it's just so much easier to
scroll through instagram and get a
couple little
little bullet points and then move on
the election man i stayed plugged in i
had multiple screens up i wanted to see
what people were saying and how they
were saying it
and they kept coming in and coming in
here's the deal my brain is fried
and so i'm calling for a personal i want
to invite you into a digital detox i'm
an intentionally disconnect from these
digital devices to give my brain and my
body
a break and to heal some of these
relationships that i've
i haven't hurt people but man i've just
started get distant
this includes all screens and all things
that come with them right
and this removes this this detoxing
removes
constant stimulation from my neural
pathways it gives me an opportunity to
reset and refocus on real life real
rhythms
the sun the moon weather
right real people waving eye contact
old school stuff and then you throw zoom
into all this by the way for those of
you who
are still working at home still
navigating that world man
enough is enough is enough and here's an
important thing before we get into some
details
you can't just take screens away you
have to backfill that
with other things that are going to fill
that time and space things are going to
make you
whole and some of that may be sleep like
we talked about in a recent podcast some
of that's going to be
intentional relationships someone's
going to be looking across the table
someone that you love saying
i miss being intimate with you
i during look back on covid and we are
now sleeping together once a month
we have held hands never we just don't
hold hands anymore
um we haven't kissed each other on the
face
in a long time kids i've just quit
hugging you
i'm checking these stupid whatever
screens all the time all day
you got to backfill that with
intentional activities intentional
relational connection moments
right so everyone should set time for a
digital detox
detox on a regular basis so here's a
couple of things that me and the team
came up with
every day think about detoxing the book
ends of your day
right so don't get on at least until an
hour
of being awake i'm saying if you go
check my
my my data on my phone i'm an idiot when
it comes to this
i screw it up i don't do it well don't
get on your screens
until at least an hour if not longer
in fact me be with people and then drive
to work
without getting on screens let being at
work be the first time you get on a
screen
and then an hour before you go to bed
get off
get off that may mean you have to go to
the public library
public library free books they just have
them there
go for walks in your neighborhood where
they have those books in those little
side
sidewalk libraries play with your kids
play board games me and my son
rediscovered mancala
dude we are gambling like crazy on
mancala for his halloween candy it's so
great
every week aim to be off screens for the
majority of one day
probably on the weekend be completely
off un freaking
plug and then every year once or twice
have an extended time of going screen
free
and i want to talk to bosses out there
if you were one of those bosses who
expects your people
to take their phone with them on
vacations
to always be accessible because that's
that's how that's how we're going to
know if they really care
bullcrap that's a you problem not a them
problem
if you are that kind of boss you are
killing your employees
you are choosing to dissect their
families and it's pissing me off
you're hurting people when people are on
vacation i want you as a boss as a
supervisor to call them and say
do not get on the phone go be whole with
your family
and bosses the the research is in
they will be better employees they will
work harder for you in their back
let them go god almighty's driving me
crazy
but go on a vacation go somewhere
and leave your phone in the car don't
think of well this is going to make a
really good instagram post
i have fallen into that trap and i've
only been on this stupid thing for
a few months okay here's a few
truths about the tech more and more
research reveals there's a strong
relationship between
increased technology use and anxiety and
depression
it's just the data guys it's just the
science get off of it
also we know this but these platforms
are highly engineered to make you want
to click on them
i'm a guy that does mental health
wellness for a living
and i am i i catch myself with it
if you watch the documentary social
dilemma you'll see it
it's real it's not a pretend thing it's
not a oh my gosh are they going to
secede from the union it's not one of
those kind of conspiracy theories
theory things they're going to vaccinate
us all and put chips in our brains just
whatever no this is for real they highly
engineer platforms to make you
want to click on them to need to click
on them
digital stimulation digital
conversations are not
communication they are information
transmission
communication is not connection
i'll say that again communication is not
connection just because you text
somebody a lot does not mean you're
connecting with them
i can text to my wife i love you 50
times in a day
i haven't connected with her i've passed
along
info that she received in about 25
of her information-absorbing receptors
in her frontal lobe that's it she got
dad a point
my husband loves me she didn't get my
eye crinkles she didn't get my
smile she didn't get my touch she didn't
get my pupils dilating
she didn't get my hug our our hearts our
heartbeats connecting together she
didn't get any of that stuff
she got some data and that's not
connection
you your smartphone is a tool it's a
hammer
it's a screwdriver it is not your friend
it does not like you it's just not
it's convenient yes it is not your
friend okay
the goal of social media apps is for you
to devote as much of your attention as
possible to the app
they monetize your time and they
monetize your attention it is a widget
it is a tool
and it is using you right so what do i
do without this
replace time on screen with
relationships replace
mindful mindless scrolling with being
intentional
cook walk kick a soccer ball
go hunting go fishing paint something
learn how to play something build
something do somersaults in your
neighbor's yard
i don't care what it is but find things
that connect you with humanity
get in touch with your true values so
many of us are letting
other people dictate our values because
i'm on that team and they're saying that
i have to think this and i guess i just
go i don't know what to do
and then do human things play in the
rain with your kids
cook a meal with a roommate try dye your
hair you're on zoom for crying out loud
no one's gonna see it
give yourself a mohawk right and then
read real books read fiction fiction i
know the cool thing is break bro i don't
have time for fiction
read fiction we'll talk about that
another thing i have a whole thing on
reading fiction
what it it how it comes into your brain
differently but at the end of the day
here's the deal
i'm calling for a digital detox i'm
going to do it normally i wait till
new year's to do some of these things
i'm starting here i'm starting right now
um to be highly intentional about my
time and just got to get off
just got to get off so that's it um so
let's take another call let's go to
kelly
in guam right down the street in guam
kelly what's going on hi dr d thank you
so much for taking my call
thanks for waiting so long while i was
ranting about digital detoxes how are we
doing
i'm okay um you know i'm calling today
about my beautiful 17 and a half year
old baby girl
all right so her teenage years have been
a little rough
for the family but particularly on me in
the last three and a half years we've
dealt with two
pregnancy scares um and we've had to
work through those things as a family
with christian values
she she's not pregnant but after working
through these events
as a family and as a mother and daughter
i find that now moving forward
i'm always suspicious of her now the
most recent scare was just this july
and i'm struggling with always
suspecting her of wrongdoing
even when she's innocent and since this
last pregnancy scare she's actually done
really well in honoring our boundaries
and our values
and i've explained to her that my trust
is very fragile
but i'm just always suspicious and i
don't want to spend the last
five months of her childhood life with
me suspicious of her and
i also don't want that to leak over into
my 10 year old son who's
coming up into adolescence so hoping for
some advice
i love that thank you so much for the
for your trust here that's i appreciate
that man that's cool
um so there's several things here let's
let's back all the way up
so you've got you said you got christian
values of your home
and so one of those values i'm going to
assume is
that you want to you don't want your
teenage daughter out having sex with
with other people right
correct okay so when you say there was
two pregnancy scare
events that sounds like a drum roll
and fireworks and lightning like
tell me what you mean when you say
events did you catch her with somebody
or did she come home and have a hard
conversation with you and say hey mom i
think i'm pregnant
did she have a pregnancy test that she
passed like tell me what the event was
okay so the first one was the more
chaotic one i actually didn't know what
had happened for over a year
when she was as young as just turning 15
she became very angry depressed dealt
with self-harm
it was just really difficult i didn't
know what was going on
i got her counseling and for a year i
just worked through this child who i
basically didn't know anymore
i had to do some work on my own self to
connect with her better
anyways after a year of this of
counseling of boundaries of working
together
um with technology exactly what you've
said about technology i had to cut her
off her
technology for over a year
we found out she was inappropriately
interacting with this boy via technology
and so her dad got involved and
contacted his parents and cut we
basically cut them off
she was barely 15. so a year later after
all of this she finally
told me mom i slept with him
and she was like i got pregnant and i
miscarried which i cannot medically
confirm because i don't
it was a year later and i don't even
know she know what that meant
right and so i mean it was a huge upset
it
dramatically affected our family but um
like i said we did a lot of hard work
and so this last event in july it was
just one of those she came home i was
like
mom i'm late for my menstruation i took
a pregnancy test it was negative and i
was like
oh my god honey well those could be
inaccurate so we spent the weekend
i took her to the doctor and i spent the
weekend crying basically
um waiting for those results those
results came back negative
after that me and her father sat her
down and we went over what our personal
values were where we stood
but the fact that she's almost an adult
and she's going to make these decisions
she's going to have to deal with them
and so that's basically how they
unfolded so the second event wasn't
i don't want to say it wasn't as
traumatic if you will
but still very it affected me greatly
so and so before i leave the first one
that's not a pregnancy scare okay if a
15 year old
got pregnant and miscarried that is a
deep deep trauma
yeah okay so that's that's not a
pregnancy scare event
um i don't know any
any adult in my life who hasn't had some
sort of pregnancy scare even if they're
married with a couple of kids
right yeah um that's that's that's that
goes with the territory
that's not what your daughter
experienced i have
um met with teenagers over the years who
become sexually active at a young age
and they go through
a whole series of depressive episodes
of like you mentioned cutting self-harm
stuff
because there's a disconnect between the
physical and the
the hormonal and then the emotional and
it just becomes a tidal wave for
for especially young teens and then you
throw into that
whether if she was truly pregnant and
truly miscarried
that's a loss of i don't know if you've
experienced that but that's a loss of
unimaginable depth that a 15 year old
just doesn't have the psychological
wiring to handle
i don't know i don't know any adult that
has the psychological wiring to handle
that on their own without a community
right
and so i want to characterize that the
right way
so then fast forward when she came to
you and said mom i'm
late and you spent the weekend crying
were you crying because your daughter
was
having sex again or were you crying
because you thought you're gonna be a
grandma
so i think my crying had more to do with
like
blaming myself like how did i let this
happen to her again
how is this your fault well because i'm
her mom
and i mean i've spent so much time
trying to talk to her about the dangers
and
yeah but you know you were 17 too
if a 17 year old wants to be a 17 year
old they're gonna be a 17 year old and
so
right it's it's you're taking a lot on
if you
if you immediately run to the mirror and
say what have i done i gave her all the
information
and we know that like sexual activity
and teenagers is
is how they try to connect right that's
that's them trying to figure it out
and so yeah you can put up all kind of
fences and stuff teenagers
we've got 400 years we got thousands of
years of literature about teenagers
figuring that out
right how to get around walls and
barriers and things yes sir
um so and i'm telling you that not to
minimize what you went through but i'm
just trying to drill down
it sounds like you felt like you failed
yeah for
your teenage daughter violating your
boundaries true but
acting like a teenage daughter
and so i i want to get at um
were you disappointed in her were you
heartbroken or did you really just land
on
i suck as a mom because it happened
again
yeah that's that's where i landed okay
so your tears were more about
your perceived failures not about any
situation your daughter was in
well mina there was a little bit of oh
my gosh what about her future right you
know there you go okay
all right what does that mean for her of
course but
she's she's so she was very stoic about
it she was like
mom i'm gonna do what i have to do if i
am pregnant like and then i'm of course
like baby i'm here for you and she's
like i know mom but
i'm going to do what i got to do i made
this choice
but i mean a lot of it because i guess
because of what i went through when she
was 14
like it's just yeah and so here's the
thing
i i i missed an important thing and i'm
going to own that i missed it
your your daughter dealt with a
unimaginable trauma
but you did too and if you're still
characterizing
the miscarriage of a future grandkid as
a pregnancy scare
that tells me you haven't dealt with it
either
and you might still be in the
performative aspect of parenting which
is
um often for evangelical christian kids
if i can keep them from having sex
drinking beer and
um smoking cigarettes and marijuana i've
won
like and if they don't say bad words
that's even a bonus on top
right and and we lump in those three or
four behaviors and those are
all well and good those are all values
behaviors those all have negative
outcomes attached to a lot of them right
but often we sacrifice connection for
trying
like truly connecting with my kid
letting them
see what i'm what i'm gonna model what
these values look like
and it really diminishes the connection
because i'm just trying to make sure
that this behavior doesn't happen and
i'm all about behavior
prohibition for teens big time big time
and i think we have um completely
swung that pendulum too far the other
way asking 13 year olds how they feel
about things i don't care you're 13
right so i'm with you on those but
you've got to process the trauma too
and i bet your husband does as well
and if you haven't sat down and you said
i'm really proud of you said you did
your own work for a year
i hope that some of that was healing was
from that too
so you've reached an important point
that i hope
every parent listening to this hears i
hope every wife and every husband
and every boss everyone who's in a
relationship with other people
you have a suspicion now you created
a picture of a world that your daughter
was going to live into
and she didn't live into it and you
probably put some boundaries
on her like you can't you've got a
curfew you can't go out this time i
don't want you talking to that boy
and somehow she was a 17 year old and
she
found her way around the boundaries and
she slept with somebody again and now
you're suspicious of everything
and you also are wise enough to know
that that living that suspicious life if
you start
trying to always be thinking about
what's on her phone what's always in her
email accounts
where she might be where she's not be
i'm going to put my phone tracker app
that you realize that you were
distilling a relationship down
into a series of points and she's going
to go away in about half a year she can
be 18 she'll be gone
and you're going to realize i burned
that last half of that thing
fretting away those moments of
connection right
that's a really astute observation for
you as a mom i hope
everyone's listening to this that we
when we turn people
into our worst fears
we are choosing to disconnect from them
so here's a couple of things i would
tell you and these are just off the top
of my head
number one you are allowed to have your
suspicions
they're real and my guess is you had
some behaviors
um expectations of your daughter which
is
right and good i'm glad you did and she
violated them again
and so you're allowed to be suspicious
right that's a normal thing
i got a 10 year old and i'm suspicious
of him i got a five-year-old and i'm
super suspicious of her
right that's normal and good also
your kid's 17 you're allowed to say let
me see your phone
you're allowed to say where are you
going call me when you get there
i don't consider that and this is i'm
going to get mean cards and letters
i don't consider that a quote-unquote
invasion of their privacy
they are children they're children they
have a door on their room because we are
nice not because they quote unquote
deserve it
okay so you're allowed to be suspicious
at the same time you are real close to
having an adult
in your home and teaching them that
autonomy and teaching them how to
lean out of that is important so here's
the what i think is the greatest gift
you could give your kid
so this is number two number one is your
suspicions are good
they're fine good for you number two is
finding a way to both be honest with
your 17 and a half year old
and wise and what i mean by that
say when you feel suspicious sit down
with your daughter and say
i'm feeling suspicious something's not
right in my gut and i have
been wrong wrong over the course of your
life
do i have anything to be suspicious
about and
let her speak into it okay and what
what what you're doing is you're you're
showing your daughter vulnerability
you're showing her leadership you're
showing her accountability
and you are saying i'm going to default
to trust even though you violated a few
big times because it sounds like
all the other times she's she's a pretty
good kid right oh yeah
um and like you said you started the
whole call with she's beautiful and
wonderful and she's had sex
and so i don't want all those things to
be divorced from one another right they
can all be
live in that same tension but by showing
her that you love her enough to hold her
accountable
and you love her enough to be vulnerable
and open with her you're gonna model for
her
what being a parent looks like you're
going to model for her what being a
christian mom looks like someone who
both loves and wants to trust and is
still struggling with
that that moment and then if you find
out that she's lying to you again you're
going to hold her accountable
if you find out she's violating your
core family values
you're going to hold her accountable and
i think
being honest with her about that tension
because here's what kids do
okay kids feel that tension on their
parents
and they backfill that tension with it's
my fault
i suck i can't make my
mom feel right about me and the way kids
interpret that is a violation of a
relationship and it's their fault
and then they set about all kinds of
different behaviors and ways of coping
with that disconnection
some kids try to be perfect some kids go
burn down the neighborhood
some kids try to get straight a's some
kids quit going to class
some kids smoke weed some kids go get
bunches of girlfriends some
fill in the blank but it's kids are
always trying to reach out and reconnect
and reform those relationships
especially when they feel that gap and
that tension with their parents
and so that tension is going to be there
when you feel that suspicion
like she's like i'll be back at 10 i'm
going to study spanish at susan's house
and your alarms go off when you're like
bull crap you're not right
like you're not and now you've got a
you've got a
backlog you've got some things where
she's gone to study
so you think and you also have some data
that says sometimes she doesn't go study
sometimes she goes and hooks up with
somebody
right then there's that tension and she
feels it you feel it you all feel it and
that's when you as the adult the wise
one get to lean into that and say
all right let's talk i my my suspicion
alarms just set off
it might be me but i was a 17 year old
girl wants to
and it might not be so here's what i
think
i think you're going to go do x y and z
and i feel like i want to look at your
phone
when i say that what do you what do you
think and let her speak into it
and then you get to own the conversation
you get to own the wisdom you get to own
the
um vulnerability there and then you let
her get to practice being an adult is
she going to be honest with you is she
going to tell you the truth et cetera et
cetera
how does that sound when i say that it
sounds
you know along the lines of what i've
been working towards
awesome because i mean yeah there was
one time like i caught her
she was up at like 4am i was like what
are you doing awake and so we had this
argument and i was just honest i said
baby you have to understand
my trust is very fragile and we have to
work together to fix that
so one thing i would add number one good
for you for having a conversation and
for leaning into that number two
four a.m is never a good time to have
existential conversations about trust
right because then she gets she's
exhausted and
that that her ability to think clearly
and respond
appropriately and respectfully is thin
and then your ability to respond
respectfully and authentically and wise
is thin that's when you circle back that
next weekend
or that next night or that evening and
say dude look 4 30. no
no way dude no teenager on in guam
is just hanging out at 4 a.m because
they're doing math homework right
they're not
right no um and so i i
i think you're right on the right track
i do
feel your feelings and just ask them for
data
for truth and if you feel suspicious
trust your gut you've been right a lot
and
lean into wisdom and trust with your
daughter i think you're
that's a good place and i want to honor
the fact that you and your husband set
boundaries and values for her
and most of the time she follows him and
a couple times she hasn't
and you still are defaulting to the fact
that you love her you think she's
wonderful
i think giving her good education and
not just scare tactics but good
education and also
being vulnerable you can't about your
own story if you have your own stories
um letting her get to see what's in the
heart and mind
of a good mom and a good wife
and a good person just trying to make
through the day
but man it sounds like y'all are right
on the right track
and the more vulnerable you can lean
into that while still holding
firm to your values and firm to that
accountability kelly you're
you're teaching a young kid
how to become a young woman how to
become a young adult
and good for you that young girl's lucky
to have you
wouldn't do 4 a.m conversations but
she's lucky to have you that's
super super good and man i'd already
picked this song
i i don't know um
i don't i don't think it's appropriate
because it's about boyfriends and things
so i'm gonna switch to another song
let's see here we're gonna go to this
song we're gonna go to one of my
favorite songs of all time
off the 1986 new order album
the name of the album is brotherhood i
love this song
it's called bizarre love triangle has
nothing to do with you guys in guam
has everything to do with bizarre love
triangles the good guy
the good folks in new order i love them
what a great team
19 1986 brotherhood album here's what
they write
every time i think of you i feel shot
right through with a bolt of blue i
don't even know what that means but it
just sounds cool
it's no problem of mine but it's a
problem i find living a life
that i can't live behind leave behind
there's no sense in telling me the
wisdom of a fool won't set you free
but that's the way that it goes and it's
what nobody knows well every day
my confusion grows and every time i see
you falling i get down on my knees and
pray
i'm waiting for that final moment you
say the words that i can't say
i have no idea what that even means but
it sounds so good
and this is the dr john dolone's show